eight news now breaking news alert  we start with this mess on i-15  major traffic backups on i-15 southbound  this is near sloan you're looking live  from some rtc cameras there  showing what was going on there was a  tractor-trailer fire  that has been causing major delays now  the fire is out but here's some video  from earlier this morning  this wasn't that long ago of our crew as  the firefighters there put the  tanker fire out on the back of that  truck again the fire is out but there  are still  major delays so if you're heading from  the valley south this is near sloan road  it's going to take you a long time might  want to hold off on that trip for a  little while  until the traffic loosens up there we'll  have the latest for you on eight news  now dot com but that is a  ongoing situation on i-15 just south of  the valley